now let's meet the cast of Dancing with
the Stars my name is Tripp I'm from
Alaska
my mom's burst on my anger was therapy
[Music]
Junior what was your reaction oh my gosh
when they Deena you know one of the
executives she texts me I was like no
way and then it was like a real thing
and of course my son at first was like
oh yeah this sounds so fun yeah I'm
gonna do it and then I like you know
showed him some clips of young dancers
I'm not doing it like we already started
the contract like you have to do it but
he had the best time of his life and
he's made lifelong friends they're like
incredible incredible time and I have
the utmost respect for the show and
everyone there so it was a great
experience for him I felt like a
complete like pageant mom like Tripp get
your act together you better smile you
better practice it was more
nerve-wracking having my son on the show
then it would have ever been to have
myself on it because it was like smile
if you don't have a good attitude like
you're gonna regret this
but um yeah way more nerve-wracking
being a mom watching it than actually
participating in the show what was the
one piece of advice you gave him for
success on the absolute start I told him
to try his best
I told him we went into it I mean he's
nine years old he was like the youngest
one on the show one of the youngest I
think and I said Tripp have fun make
friends you know learn some manners with
girls you know how are you gonna you're
gonna learn how to dance just have fun
make friends and that's what he did he
had such an amazing time and their
memories that he's gonna have forever
you